every single time you tell yourself
you're going to do something and you
don't follow through with it you are
telling your subconscious mind that you
don't trust yourself to follow through
so you're actually losing confidence
within yourself let's say you commit to
posting every single day number one
you're committing to yourself number two
you're committing to your followers so
it's not a good mindset hack to not be
consistent if you decide you're going to
build this brand and you're going to
post consistently but also your
followers aren't going to want to keep
following you cuz they're not going to
trust you that they're going to get the
content every single day so they're
going to go follow someone else that's
consistent